hey guys we are Gert and I'm Chris
waters and it's Friday which means I've
got a stack of top 5 music hold on hold
on didn't you say we're gonna have like
a super special guest today yes you
should hell we should wait for the real
special guest account no I meant you if
you oldest special guest Jessamine a
platter but like I host the show I was
doing it last week i'm not exactly
special no like I did I didn't mean you
I meant you yeah it seriously uh-huh
what was it cliffy B wouldn't return my
calls
the past two weeks have brought us
plenty of announcements in game trailers
that just couldn't wait for e3 but 3 e3
hit new heights yesterday with a full-on
press conference from oculus VR the big
show piece was the new consumer model of
the oculus rift which will be packaged
with a headset and an external sensor
for positional tracking as well as a
wireless Xbox one controller and an
adapter for connecting it to your PC the
Microsoft connection goes beyond the
bundled controller however the rift will
have native support for Windows 10 and
you'll be able to stream your xbox one
games through your PC to the oculus rift
and play them in a kind of virtual
cinema they showed off a bunch of
trailers some from 3rd person view which
was kind of odd but the big reveal came
at the end with the oculus touch check
this thing out you'll recognize some
familiar controller II bits triggers
buttons etc but it's also got these
bracelet things that will recognize hand
poses and arm flails and make it sting a
bit more when you accidentally clock
someone with them the oculus rift is
coming out in q1 2016 for consumers and
I for one I'm pretty excited about it
what do you think Jessie you are you
into it into VR Jess are you Jeff whoo a
treasure chest in unexpectedly
groundbreaking news an online-only game
launched this week and it's kind of
really broken must be Tuesday this time
around the game in question is
Bethesda's Elder Scrolls online which
hit xbox one and ps4 a few days ago a
bunch of players began reporting login
problems on NeoGAF and the official ESO
forum file complaints of error codes
getting booted off servers and other
infuriating login kerfuffles are still
being reported today Bethesda has
promised gamers they're working to fix
these issues but for those of you who
dropped money on the elder scrolls
online Tamriel unlimited there's not a
whole lot of comfort right now given the
experience for some appears to be pretty
bloody limited
the weekend is here do you know what
you're playing I'm playing III prep
simulator 2015 which includes such
classics as do laundry shave and get
some sleep for the love of God if you're
looking for something equally exciting
to tempt you there are tons of deals on
right now hot off news that more people
are playing The Witcher 3 on GOG than
steam the to digital distribution
platforms are going head-to-head in a
summer sale showdown in which the winner
will be you and the loser will be your
bank account there are new deals every
24 hours on Steam new deals twice a day
on GOG so check them out for yourself at
your own risk on the console side
microsoft announced their deals with
gold for the first half of june which
includes discounted prices for sunset
overdrive EA sports games and more see
the full list on gamespot com / news or
just download massive chalice for free
on your xbox one and spend a weekend
carrying out a grand eugenics experiment
to ensure the survival of your realm
sorry asthmatics no procreation for you
kotaku have NAB's themselves a bunch of
info on the upcoming destiny expansion
so if you came to kick some pies ask for
double the rise of the previous destiny
expansions give all the latest on that
allegedly the expansion entitled the
taken king is going to be way bigger
than any extra content pack destiny fans
have been treated to so far of course if
you want the new multiplayer maps strike
missions and other features it sounds
like you'll be forking out a ton of
glimmer for the privilege supposedly the
expansion will run you 40 bucks although
Activision are trying to make it worth
your while by including a new subclass
for each of the three classes as well as
three new Elemental super abilities so
you can rip your foes apart in style
said those include Oryx who you'll be
facing off against in a new raid Oryx is
the father of crota who's probably none
too pleased about you often his son in
the crotas end' raid 2 expansion packs
ago take all that with a grain of salt
since bungee is yet to officially
confirm any details on the up
expansion when you think I want to watch
a video you think YouTube when you think
I want to watch a video of someone
playing video games you think twitch but
youtube doesn't like that youtube wants
to be your one and only youtube is
YouTube has announced plans for a big
gaming push that includes a website and
a nap focused entirely on games content
thousands of game specific pages will
allow you to track content for games
you're interested in but perhaps the
bigger move is into the live streaming
space among the features there boasting
our high frame rate streaming at 60fps
DVR automatically converting your stream
to a YouTube video and creating a single
link you can share for all your streams
there were reports last year that Google
is going to bite which a deal which fell
through of course so now Google's taking
a shot at the live streaming king and
twitch has returned the volley with a
sassy tweet ooh right in the Google+
sweet news we will also have a bunch of
breaking these next week at this III
show you ma'am sure will oh oh guys I
just get excited III like press
conferences live demos it's like we get
to talk to the people who make the games
we get to see the awesome games and we
got to bring it all to you there's gonna
be tons of awesome stuff you guys aren't
gonna want to miss it it's a good time
we love it and we can't wait to see you
that well I mean they'll they'll see us
yeah we might see them that we'll figure
it out it'll be fine it's gonna be cute